up okay go ahead counting you in
in
music okay
counting you in in five four three
i just want to say that uh they produced
a great one
people say people allowed like 60
minutes they say oh this is
journalism journalism 60 minutes
wouldn't have the guts
to have the gorilla glue spray girl call
into the show
good luck ethan thank you keemstar
uh here let me show you guys the tick
tock i'm talking about because this is
really exciting that she's going to call
on because she's kind of a big deal
right now and i have so many questions
for her
um tessica if you guys haven't seen this
year and for a treat
this is exciting you guys we have an
exclusive it's so exciting it says 10
million views after like one day
whoa yeah it's epic my hair has been
like this for about a month now
it's not my choice no
it's not my choice when i do my hair i
like to
you know finish it off with a little got
to be glue spray you know just to
keep it in place well i didn't have any
more got to be glue space so i use this
gorilla glue this is a good commercial
for gorillas
it really is i was like damn yeah is
this just viral marketing is there a
chance
it don't move wash my
run out of got to be glue spray don't
ever
ever use this unless you want your head
to be like that
like i mean you know with peace and love
i never i didn't need that warrant
my hair is better i can't believe this
is even she seems funny she seems
interesting
here people are going like come on what
is this so she makes a follow-up video
here i'm following her the whole saga
she's like you want
she shows you shampoo right on it yeah
that's crazy man god
don't you feel like this should be
scottie like look
look yo look at this look you wipe it
off and nothing happens
how could this happen it's gorilla glue
i mean those guys don't [ __ ] around
those guys are like military grade
they've been in the lab for decades
i gotta ask her if there's anything
convenient about it though because like
it does look fire you don't have to do
your hair at least it doesn't look bad
like that's fire
like you know she went out that first
day being like my hair is on point right
now
do you think it could maybe be hurting
i mean because your hair if she's had
that for a month you have to assume the
hair is growing
but it's not moving so something
something's up
something's going on there could it be
hurting yeah probably
i mean definitely
yeah that's what her hair follicles are
singing
um there's a third update
okay thank you thank you i love these
updates of the slideshows and stuff
thank you guys for encouraging words and
and then there's just no way
i can read that and any idea to get rid
of it forever i will try some today
okay i'm trying to run as fast again and
ponytail i'll try something today when i
get oh
okay pretty fast and from work today i
will keep you guys posted by the way if
you're out
if you're walking around and ahead
scarf and head don't mind okay whatever
you know so
gorilla glue responded to her was like
uh try
alcohol and water or something but i
mean from what i can understand nothing
has worked
okay so i'm about to go to bed i put
coconut
and tea tree oil and plastic on it i'll
update you
i mean i could tell you right now that
[ __ ] ain't gonna work yeah
that [ __ ] ain't gonna work i mean she
might die with gorilla glue on her head
oh my god
of old age of course not of anything
else
so tessica is calling in later and i
mean that that that is a thrill to me
yeah and then there's one other person
actually he was just
oh he says can we push you closer to one
that's fine big nick is calling in too
because
um well big nick was someone who used to
be on the vlog squad
right who i always liked i thought he
was interesting
and um he had a falling out with david
too and he saw us talking about
it on the last episode of frenemies and
he dm'd me and said yo
um he had some comments about what we
said so i said do you want to call in
and he said yes so big nick is calling
him okay
huge shout out to his family shout out
to his family
so i have something to show off to you
either yeah
i've been wondering what is this cube
it's the joel austin button
oh
there's daily inspiration the sermon
daily affirmation and favorites which
one do you want to hear so
you're supposed to just keep this around
yeah you just put on the desk it tells
you the time
this ugly thing how dare you this is the
joe austin queue
it's supposed to be inspired how much
was this dan
uh well i bought it on ebay resale
yeah not stockx yeah not stockx
um but i might throw it up there later
not far french i think it was like 50
bucks 40 bucks
oh wow nice good deal so do you want
inspiration sermon or affirmation
inspiration
smile yeah here we go
here we go
paused english you can't become who you
were created to be
always depending on somebody else you
don't need that crutch
start encouraging yourself all through
the day
i am strong in the lord something good
is going to happen to me
god being for me is more than the world
being against me
some of the things god the [ __ ] you
talking about y'all oh my god
if someone is unironically doing this on
their daily life
you know why is he gonna talk like that
i would be confused
and i'll see you into the lord to be who
you need to be
it's like who the [ __ ] is here i want to
try a affirmation
affirmations victory
god's supernatural favor over your life
what you couldn't make happen on your
own god is going to make happen for
you supernatural opportunities healing
restoration breakthroughs are coming
your way
what kind of advice is that he's like
whatever you can't do on your own
as long as you see that sorry victory
don't you stop seeing sewing
more affirmations yeah i declare
god's supernatural heard it dummy
would you consider that all he's got the
sound oh it is surprisingly good
yeah it is pretty good yeah it is
actually pretty good
bro can you give me something else like
holy [ __ ] find this speaker quality
inspiring
oh you were created in the image of god
you have the dna of a winner you are
wearing a crown
royal blood flows through your veins you
are the head
and not the tail above and never beneath
i declare that you will live with
purpose passion
and praise knowing that you were
destined to live in victory
okay don't you know if you're listening
to this button that all this shit's not
true about you
you're like you're bro you're buying a
joel osteen motivational button
it should really say hey idiot you're
[ __ ] you bought a joel osteen
motivational button do you really think
you're going anywhere
yeah next let's get some what are we
going to do
i declare god's incredible blessings
over your life
shut up you will see an explosion of
god's goodness a sudden
you will experience the surpassing
greatness of god's favor
it will elevate you to a level higher
than you ever dreamed
explosive blessings explosive
i can't listen to him i don't i don't
need any explosive blessings right now
he talks too long i remember being
shorter i didn't i wasn't expecting a
whole [ __ ] sermon i was just
expecting like
you're beautiful imagine having to
explain this to someone it's just
hanging on your table here's the thing
if you have this i feel like no
no explanation needed i feel like it's
not it's like the opposite of
inspirational it's like a daily reminder
how pathetic your life is yeah
um shout out to joel osteen making a
killing everywhere he goes
jesus hey um ian what's going on
in your frame
up what do you i don't know what you're
referring to
okay all right no worries okay
how you doing zach doing pretty good
doing pretty good nice how are you doing
how's it going with the family with all
the lot you're living with the family
you got everything going on how's it
living with your folks you've been in
the same house with them for a long time
uh it's uh it's getting time to move out
do you fight with them a lot um
you know quarantine like a lot of other
families of um
you know when you're with someone too
much it causes conflict but you know
i love my family very diplomatic good
yeah yeah
um having said that
is time to move out all right well we
wish you luck
the joker brain needs to joke and move
up
right av you got a little ninja going on
today god bless you getting playing some
fortnite later
no i just uh my hair's at that awkward
stage so
rocking the bandana all right he he
called me and he said he's all zach how
do i get your flow
he did yeah wait what does that mean for
heritage yeah you
yeah he's like i want to grow my hair
out like you yeah
oh yeah sure you're lying based on it
yeah tells a different story
and ian is just in the jungle no but
there is there seems to be a
a ai figurine behind you yeah not creepy
at all
behind you well he doesn't like when i
talk to him or look at him
it's normal as usual don't push it don't
push it
i see what is what's he watching uh he
appears to be watching terminator
which one he said he had studying to do
i don't i don't know studying oh boy
so most people watch terminator for the
story but not
i have a feeling he's watching it for
tips
okay let's not destroy it let's not
disturb it and just
just keep it together
shout out to his family
so listen to this um but you know we
could we would
take keeping it too serious here on on
after dark so we kind of went old school
with that
really we got a bunch of fun clips to
watch
lots of goofy little meme holes to fall
down
good starting with this one here
which combines a few of my favorite
things
um this is tick tock man this
was on my feed like it doesn't get
better
except when tick tock doesn't work i
mean what
love it yeah we love that
here we go so i mean
one dude he takes a tumble
because this cart and then another lady
she oh another old lady she's like
i can't stop this
and then there's a normal like a like a
yeah the lady in the back isn't
i'm wondering what could she do because
it's just
it's just inevitable this lady in the
back is kind of just watching it all
happened
my first thought was like how was she
not helping more but then i kind of come
to realize like
what can she actually do
why his car got stuck on the thing
he's old as [ __ ] dude he can't get out
of the way
i couldn't really tell yeah he's yeah
he's really he doesn't want to be there
and be trampled on
i don't know ladies
oh that's
that's what being old is in one image
man
just being helpless to an escalator [ __ ]
see his wheel gets caught i mean that
ain't right whatever store that is that
ain't right
you know he's probably never going to
recover from that i mean that is aged i
mean peace and love
oh it's just she she knows it's gonna
happen but
she just can't fight it it's just the
slow motion
i love it is there a way to zoom in i
don't know what's happening
i don't know i don't know oh maybe maybe
i don't know this whole tick tock on the
browser tick tock on the browser step
your [ __ ] up i mean
seriously here's another tip or
well so thoughts on that i mean
oh man that was magnificent
you think anyone was seriously injured
shout out to his family
not necessarily meanwhile that one dj be
like
okay um
this [ __ ] scared the hell out of me i
put this on
and i was like holy [ __ ] because i do
not want to challenge the pack
you tell me what you think about this
oh you little bastard you want to
challenge my pack
well i hate to say this but i'm not the
alpha that you want to challenge
because my true alpha is right there
so if you want to challenge one of us
you have to go through
all of us
so true i'm back so true
i stepped down because i had to
now i'm back
so you want to challenge
let's challenge you want to fight me
one-on-one
well listen up well she was my trainer
so i suggest you shut up and set your
ass
down before you have to deal with
him and i'm ready
and we're all ready
this was just on your tick tock oh no
this one was
one of the guys i'm not quite sure
what's the story behind this clip
yeah who found this interesting
that was on my tick tock oh you like
that was on your tick tock
yeah so yeah i mean tick tock is
undisputed the best
platform that's amazing yeah i mean the
stuff that shows up on mine
it's amazing the stuff that shows up on
my
feed you couldn't find anywhere else in
the world it's like an art gallery
so what do you think they're responding
to probably like one random commenter
who was like
i mean that you suck he's like you suck
and this is their response
that is uh how we should all react to
online if if bullying if theodore ever
gets bullied at school i'm sending this
video to
his their dad i saw somebody in the
in the chat say uh the mom is so funny i
got bad news i don't think that's the
mom
yeah what i don't think that's the mom
that's not the mom
yeah oh i know that ain't the mom trust
me
that's a love triangle bro that's a pack
okay
three throuple i saw a really funny
video on my
own tick tock page last night though i
want to show you guys real fast
this just showed up i feel like i don't
get this stuff i only get like
because you don't go deep into the meme
hole because they know like for example
when i get a video
a weird ass video i usually share it
right or like it
and so they go oh this guy likes the
weird [ __ ]
so this is me reacting to it but that's
not important
i just want to show come on
this just shows up on my feet i'm like
oh my god what the [ __ ]
i don't know what they're doing i don't
know what they're making
it's so um it's called yummy playing in
the background
it's like so close to their fingers
you've got that yeah
i don't think it would do much damage if
it hit your hand because it's on the goo
you know huh okay
you know what i mean are they trying to
shove it into a hole or something
i think they're just mixing it oh okay
uh working on that but it's literally
just in cement and it's just going you
got that
yummy yummy and i was like wow that
looks like a finger
going in a poopy butthole it's crazy
but this is the kind of stuff i live for
and like there's no other platform that
does it
no impossible fisting oh
i see that maybe that's what it is
what else do you have any other um
observations about it uh
ugandan
kind of angry kind of i mean maybe it's
cool you know what i look at like on the
piece of wood
sometimes like brown poo comes flying
off it like watch this
like it comes ricocheting off and then
yeah
and then they eat their poo poo right
that's not right
that's not right
this is seek okay here's a
sick here is a uh
here's a meme hole that was suggested by
a discord user on our and our discord
uh l whammick
43 suggested that apparently this
came up on their tick tock okay this
[ __ ] freaked me out and i'm not saying
that even as a joke
he says i came across this channel and
it's russian they own a farm
the videos show people spray painted
purple and living in storage crates
come on man okay i swear to god
so i'm gonna go to their youtube channel
because it's just a little easier to
navigate
but their logo is this like
this line with like a third eye which i
don't know just strikes me as some weird
deep web pedal [ __ ]
i don't know why see what i mean
it's got like a human face it's just
it's not right
right so um
here let me give you an example here
watch this i mean the [ __ ]
bro yeah play
is this human trafficking [ __ ] like it's
just cute all right sure the other guy's
covered in purple true
you can't explain it
doesn't make any sense you know and
probably wouldn't help us at all
i mean then there's this one was like i
was like what the [ __ ] this one scared
the [ __ ] out of me because
i was watching this late at night and
the music was super loud and i was like
this is
[ __ ] crazy
so like this guy's covered in like black
soot and i mean
what the hell yeah i mean what exactly
i got dead i got spooked hard
with the spray is this guy's eye [ __ ]
or is it all just black
one of them looked like the i [ __ ] and
then that guy he looks dead
so this is some real dark web [ __ ] on
tick tock
dude i got i seriously got so scared
when i because this is the first video i
opened
there's a whole bunch of them they have
a youtube channel everything man so
what's on the youtube
it's the same content but longer i'll go
over there in a minute
so here here's homie this one
is that in the video or that it is
how can you tell
guys i mean someone explained this to me
someone explained this to me this is not
how one
human human beings are meant to live i
know that
you know like holy [ __ ] dude this is
just
depraved [ __ ]
oh no here's one with a kid in blue no i
can't yeah i don't like that
i don't like that at all
what are they doing oh this is the same
oh dude what the hell he's covered in
hay bro
what and they have cows the cows live
well
oh they have like processing why would
why are they uploading pictures of
oh god he's bleeding no or it's bright i
don't know
oh was it spray why
the kim jong-un the kim jong-un threw me
off big time
okay so let's try to make this out that
guy's dead for sure
but now this one this gets me really
weird like dude is sleeping under hay
is there any way they're willing
participants yeah
i mean yeah i think it
they are but this is so weird dude's
sleeping in hey i don't know if you saw
again
dude is just sleeping out in the open
okay is this
bleeding from the head is it oh maybe
maybe it is
it might be pain maybe it must be pain
right just based on the
friend yeah yeah yeah they don't believe
in violence these people
and then this one really sealed the deal
right
so i don't know if i should be worried
or was that a message to us
but he's out of here here they are happy
let's say or someone's happy i don't
know if it's them
dude you know what this reminds me of
like he's got like cow horns on his
helmet this reminds me of like uh true
detective [ __ ]
like what goes on on the farm yeah they
just refer to it as the farm
right all right you go what the hell is
going on out there on the farm
here's another homie
you know the other weird thing is like
why are they putting this on the
internet
what the [ __ ] he's smoking i mean that's
a sign of uh
called patches of his hair missing it's
just a sign
ordering yeah he looks amazing
you know he's probably like please help
me this is the address i'm at
and it's just some tapping music over it
yeah i just want to know if we should be
calling that the authorities or what so
i'm just trying to understand as much as
much as possible
oh here's homie not covered in paint
there you go there you go
he's living life
having a good day
they're having a good day
just a couple cool guys helping us oh
[ __ ] i think he's just drunk all the
time
that's kind of [ __ ] up so [ __ ] up
oh here's you getting sprayed here's
happening see this is interesting
now here's a what's with the mute the
person who is doing this like why
so now the the emojis is laughter so
that's apparently
what i'm supposed to be feeling maybe
they're getting high
off the pain fumes
yeah maybe yeah there's better ways to
do it yeah there's way better ways
there's way better ways to do it yeah
that's not what's happening
the [ __ ] is wrong with you it was to get
high would just be under no
no yeah it would be why would you do it
there's way better ways
it's like the dudes in uh mad max the
recent map max just spray the
paint in their face so right
so what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i mean the creepiest thing is like who's
the guy
filming and spraying is he just keeping
them drunk and using them as weird tick
tock
i just i don't want to watch the [ __ ]
here here's homie
pretty good coverage today homie and
purple really good coverage today
let's see what the music is
this [ __ ] is wild
i can't believe what i'm saying vladimir
putin this is just
is this not the most bizarre content
you've ever come from yes
yep big time
they're definitely always strong oh he's
in a good mood
he's kicking it shredding
yeah it would help if we had a trend
translation maybe
but let's go over the youtube channel
and see if there's any clues there
you know so 1 000 subscribers i mean
this is a deep cut folks
this is like just so deep
so deep in the meme hall
oh my god cool you don't need to travel
it's like here we are
of course it is there's nothing normal
about these videos
nothing normal let me watch this one
i don't know about all this but yeah
yeah no i know but this you know this is
the this is what's happening we're
investigating
oh god wait don't show the screen right
now
oh they're just skinning an animal of
course they are though
you know what i mean should i show it
no okay i just saw a bloody corpse but
it was just an animal hopefully it's an
animal
as an animal come on
come on
what is this i just love her fighting oh
they're fighting
oh they're really fighting
oh [ __ ] these are yeah these are the two
homies the blue and
purple guys are going for it having a
disagreement they're having a
disagreement for sure
but why is his pants off that's what
kind of thing
they're fighting he appears to have a
shirt in his mouth
yeah i really didn't know what to expect
coming to this youtube channel
i don't know man these guys are living a
unique life i know that
they might be living the only people in
the world living the life they're living
right now
a true original
video trailer park russia will be
upstairs i feel like this could be a
show
there you go all good
god i wish we had a translation oh here
he is drawing with pancake batter
do we have people in the chat that
understand anything what is this
uh i haven't seen anybody say that we
got a donation from someone who says i
speak russian
these are just drunk russians living in
province very bored so they're trying to
make something fun it's not that
weird yeah what had a feeling what's
with the purple and blue ink you really
don't think it's that weird
they're just i never seen anything like
this in my life you're telling me this
isn't weird
well you've never lived in uh
in a remote province of russia yeah i
guess
oh so you're telling me in the
countryside of russia they're just
spraying their whole bodies purple and
blue
well these guys are weirdos they're
trendsetters
am i the only one that thinks this is
odd i mean okay this guy is clearly dead
but okay
oh it's just this tick tock here you
tell me this guy
all right all right i guess it's not
weird here's a dead dude painted purple
not weird at all
so [ __ ] me
i guess the movie
i was captivated by that i mean yeah
bizarre
i know what i want to do this weekend
gila uh-huh spray paint it up you blue
or purple
i like the purple how about the purple
all right picnic's calling in that one
until i mean here's another weird
channel so i'll go i don't know if you
guys think this one's weird but i
thought this one was really [ __ ]
weird so this one is a pie
it's like a as far as i could tell it's
like a pie fetish channel
sort of i mean there's no there's
nothing graphic
there's a highly uh political slant to
it too on top of
fetish i think that's part of the fetish
somehow
it might take but there's nothing sexual
or
or not safe for work it's just
let me sort by popular give you guys a
good
sunflowers revenge of course it's called
500 subscribers
um it's all about 500 subscribers yeah
more deep cut than the other guys have
like a thousand yeah
yeah this is way deeper
a proponent of justice for
palestine i'm 60 years old
if need be i will fight the zionist jew
for another that's me i think and yeah
justice for palestine
now i'm not sure how that equates to
justice for palestine but i believe you
yeah this is sunflower's birthday
creaming part
two of course part of a trilogy
what a pie face okay what is this gonna
have to do with palestine
either if i have to explain that then
you clearly don't understand
paul juice she looks pretty good with
the head full of cream pretty good
she starts to beg for mercy there's
narrations
i think it's shaving cream based on
other videos i've seen oh
so it's not like fun it's not like fun
eating ah
yeah that's that's why i feel like it's
all about humiliation so they end up
saying all this weird [ __ ]
and they're in and the crazy thing is
they're in an actual dressing salon like
in another video i saw clients there
getting their hair done while this was
going on what the [ __ ]
okay some people want a birthday cake
sunflower wants a birthday pie in her
face
humiliate her again she really wants it
oh god not another pop
completely
that is one totally creamed chinese head
it literally says that
doesn't she look great
she's feeling the humor oh my god let's
what the [ __ ]
is this one weirder or less weird than
the last one
i love the narration
there's a photo this one is almost weird
well there's no debate on this one like
the other one i can kind of understand
they're drunk
i i don't understand that one but this
one we're not debating
like this one is is undeniably weird and
then smacking her head
with all that nice cream i'm reading the
narration it literally says it's on the
screen
also the titles show up with like this
effects every time
and now our girl is going to get a nice
birthday shampoo
man this guy's good like he could stack
that [ __ ] like
yeah he's got a talent i think he
doesn't seem confused at all no it's
like he knows what they're there to do
well this isn't his first rodeo i'm sure
man she can breathe i mean what the f
apparently this isn't my first rodeo
right
okay toms she is getting thoroughly
punished
look at the creamy mop of long hair
this is supposed to do something to
someone yeah i mean it's obviously some
kind of fetish
i don't know who's fetish or who's
directing this or if it's her or if it's
him or what the [ __ ]
you know
that's all that's on this channel this
is it oh my god
you do you want to watch uh total cream
humiliation part two
i thought that's what we just watched no
that was birthday creaming part two
oh this one looks pretty wild the finale
she looks great
so here we go oh wow behind there's a
picture of putin and
and the chinese uh
winning the poop i believe he's called
here i'll read the description our
lovely heroine here let me play it of
course don't
now that our dear girl has had her head
totally creamed and has been completely
and publicly humiliated
she will take more punishment so weird
welcome to ccb creaming number five part
three
i'll read the description for you guys
now
this was her before my mother
one bomb i think i'm all gone
sunflower isn't emotionally exhausted
but passionately pleads her case
coming forward and know what's happening
around the world
she's giving a political plea at the
moment not in singapore
singapore we cannot allow them
because the minute president
the time has come to reveal why our dear
lady is so upset
all this day is all it's about what
happened to our dear singaporean cream
heads
the one will be
she's not upset about the cream fight
for the record she's upset about
some kind of political um issue
happening in the world probably they
have to do a zionist
oh jesus our lovely heroine sunflower
takes on the zionists yet again
and reveals the truth about their
treachery and evil plots
she will once again be creamed for her
cause
yeah all jews yeah i get that i mean you
know
zionists for sure always up to something
because you are so stupid exciting
pictures
i repeat again i will be continued
how did this still come together to make
this content
she will not stop creaming ila
she will not stop the creaming until
palestine is free
come on man can anyone make the
connection with putin and gp
in the background to what you say
i i mean it seems like she's got a
really
idiocentric set of beliefs i don't know
they said that she's from singapore
which you know is not it's an
independent
state it's like a city-state it's not
part of china uh
but maybe she's pro-china in singapore
i really don't know
yeah thank you dan oh the the homie has
got
he's in uh yeah he's
dressed like a vampire with a little
cream in his hair i mean it's wild i
don't know
so there was there's another channel
right where uh let's see here
there's a second and third channel that
all seemed to be
yeah when i found this i was like maybe
this is a
a thing of like these head creamings or
whatever so i went
looking for more and uh oh no this isn't
the
hey taylor no this isn't the other
channel what the f is this
this was in their favorite one yeah in
one of their one of the channels they
had a favorite playlist
and it just was other videos of people
getting pied okay so this is an
anti-bowling video so they found other
pie
videos i guess and then they've compiled
it so
like there's always three videos from
the playlist
well a lot of them were erased well
here's another one being suggest more
pies in the face from tiktok
yeah this is like this isn't related at
all
right suggestion here are you sure
it's not related and then here's the
other one four sexy female brazilian
models get
full pie in the face
obscure fetish pie in the face
yeah does she look better with pie in
the face so again why are they doing it
so much
like
let's go dude this is good it doesn't
get better than this folks
it's so good i'd
have to go on the hair right right
man this was like
um so let's go to the second channel
here
and see there's three channels uh
they're all fascinating so this one
this one actually has more subs i found
this one second oh two point five
thousand shampooing king 2019. it's
clearly the same
people oh here's the lady yeah and the
hair
hair salon our deer
oh trump 2020 yeah a lot of the videos
are very pro trump
stuff although if you look closely
you'll notice it's a red hat with just
something printed and sticked on it wow
she's just doing it she's doing it those
maga hats are expensive you know
you're very special
our dear mysterious header dresser can't
discourage this trump lunatic from
wanting her hedge shaved cream oh she's
a trump lunatic
anyway cut to the chase you get the idea
it's like cut forward you know what to
expect
how many times do they do this but so on
this video
on this channel you can see there's just
a collection of
people getting pied uh here
more models getting pied so dicks out uh
vin diesel seems to be from the same
brazilian show
man this this show is something else bro
it's just just models getting pied i
mean you can't beat that anywhere
not in this life so okay
when it's looking at such beauty so this
one intrigued me
because it actually has 180 000 views
it's super old which makes me think it's
just weird
let me read the comments it's all the
same guys
here it says it's a wham hall of fame
all timer
so like there's some community here i'm
trying to figure out what it is
someone look up wham how's it spelled
w a m just w-a-m
yeah hair mess and then i see other
people describe it as best hair message
i looked for hair mess
stuff and it really didn't come up with
anything but i'll look for wham videos
yeah there's some kind of community here
i'm trying to crack
but here here it is apparently they love
the hair
oh yeah oh that's pretty that's pretty
wild
oh that's aggressive pie in the face
this is true detective [ __ ] right here
boy i
don't like it so it's a hair mess
classic
and the music that's them i don't like
it
you don't like this let me just fast
forward a little bit
oh here we go i gotta i gotta i got an
update here
go ahead wet and messy fetishism
otherwise known as wham also known as
sploshing
is a form of sexual fetishism whereby
the person becomes aroused when copious
amounts of substances are applied to
naked skin face or clothing
i think this is it look at it oh this is
crazy
look at how i see i didn't watch this
deal yo this is
next level they got eggs they got food
they got cream
i mean i have never seen anything like
this in my life
and there's like flour i mean
my goodness how much did a gig like that
pay
oh my goodness she can't stop screaming
oh maybe you found lots of porn related
to this
jack came up i'm pornhub okay we figured
out what we're watching
it's called wet and messy oh you saw him
pornhub oh man
well yeah he's a fetish what and messy
wet and messy spit in my mouth look in
my eyes
what am wham oh dude you let's
go now we're talking wet and messy
i'm a little afraid there's some more
exactly just watch like yeah
you think i'm going too risky yeah this
is pretty risky
yeah oh [ __ ] did you show that dan yes
why it was on screen you're not supposed
to show the screen when it's risky
okay well i i cut away and showed the
side of someone's leg
yeah that's true so this is gonna be
okay
oh god this one looks crazy bro
that's some wet messy right there boy i
gotta get out of here
oh baked beans yeah you can put this on
holy [ __ ]
we hit him with the baked beans the
nacho cheese
this is some wet this is a good wet
messy
wham classic i don't like it you don't
like the lambs
i have the perfect idea why don't we
play hang on birthday okay this is the
last one
i don't like it yeah i'm sorry i'm just
going down the meme hole i i don't know
where it
is gonna take me comments off come on
while you play me like that okay
well we figured it out at least we did
get to the bottom of it
it's always some kind of a fetish yeah
i mean we discovered quite a lot of
fetishes on this show that that i had
i would ever guess like you remember the
um
the cast fetish yeah that one was real
interesting
the hole in the ground the ground that's
my favorite the whole
yeah holding the ground hard to top the
hole in the ground
let's wipe this claim with some
inspiration from joel austin
i think we need all a little bit of a
palette cleanser
you can't become who you were created to
be always
depending on somebody else you don't
need that crutch
start encouraging yourself all through
the day
i am strong i heard this one dude some
people never
succeed because they're not willing to
say goodbye
to the familiar goodbye to a friendship
that's holding them back goodbye to a
job where they're not fulfilled
or goodbye to old mindsets to limited
thinking
when you know you're supposed to take us
too long bro
too long wrap it up [ __ ]
it's supposed to just be a quick little
hey how are you
the speaker quality oh give me that link
guys listen to big uh big nick the link
i don't know he's gonna follow that up
but that's right here send me the link
on um
sure on whatsapp
hey come on i'm trying stop don't deader
me zack i dare you
i was trying to get zach to put the
gorilla glue hairspray in his hair
he said he'd do it for a rolex a rolex
i do for a rolex simulator yeah you
don't even know how long it would last
i will do anything for a rolex american
so
i asked how much he said it was twelve
thousand i was like
wait twelve thousand that's like kind of
doable
wouldn't mind doing that and like you
could be walking like that for months
but i'd have a rolex submariner and you
can't cut your hair like you have to let
the natural course
play itself out i'd have a rolex
submariner so i'd be like
12 000. just for rolex you could
probably buy one now if you really
wanted it
that much interesting can i see the
rolex you like
can we look at it yeah let me see what
this rolex is all about rolex
just a stainless black face 2020 you
like that 20 21
the 2020 they kind of went through a
little body change
the bezel's a little different you're a
watch guy huh
yeah i am what's the nicest watch you
have
uh this company called
you know it's like a i don't know 300
watch
that i wear and um yeah
i'm a rolly boy he says he's ready big
nick i just
i sent him the link dan okay all right
do you see this green zach
uh is this the one the submariner i mean
that's the classic one you know
it's the classic watch and it's only
watching so what do you love about this
these are all this is what you want
that's that yeah it's just an iconic
look and it'll last your whole life and
it's
do you think when people see that on
your wrist like when you see someone
with that on the wrist what do you think
about them
well what i love about it it's not super
flashy it doesn't have like diamonds or
anything like that
yeah but it's a rolex right it is flashy
so what you love about it is it costs 12
grand and it looks like it costs a
hundred
no it doesn't look like costs 100 it's
just the craftsmanship that goes into
a rolex well let me ask you this i'm so
surprised that you care about that so
much
yeah i'm a big watch guy is your dad in
the watches
uh he is but not to the extent of
like i am so what does it mean if you
see someone walking around the street
with a submariner what do you think
about them does it give you positive
like uh impression of them
yeah it means that this guy is a hard
worker you know he's not like
have diamonds coming popping out like
he's a hard worker
yeah he's not you're saying a hard
worker so what does it mean if you've
got one if i buy you one
no i'm kidding what do you mean i'm just
kidding
you are a hard worker uh big nick
is in the way of the room more well i'm
coming back to this topic later zach
you're not off the
with the watch shenanigans okay okay but
i mean this might be a worthy investment
for me
really thank you like about a thousand
for a gorilla glue spray in the hair
yeah my oh my oh i just i would feel bad
doing that yeah
i don't want to turn into this guy who
like you'd have to like
who knows how long it would last does it
really have the same dignity like you're
a working man you've got all this class
but if people know how you earned that
watch doesn't it take away from the
respectability a little bit
story's even [ __ ] better really yeah
i have to say that it does people won't
believe you
yeah they'll be like that didn't happen
somebody spoke
someone came to you they might be
inclined to believe him if he has a
shaved head all of a sudden which is
what's gonna happen if he does that
i don't know if it's because i didn't
grow up like
knowing what a rolex is or even seeing
one in my life so
it doesn't do anything to me i don't
even it doesn't even look special to me
it's but that's what i love the
simplicity well it's not even a status
quo
no no no no like that in all honesty no
no like
it it's the craftsmanship that goes into
that watch is so
immense it's a watch come on this is the
2021
machines make this [ __ ] you don't need a
little bit you have a smartphone dude
you can tell the time with your
smartphone okay
i'm saying i will do anything for this
look it's a status symbol it's fine
we all have status symbols i will do
anything for that watch literally
anything
well we got something to think about but
i don't i don't want to turn see i don't
want to turn in i don't like these
youtubers who like pay
people to do obscene [ __ ] so there's
like that
i don't like the dance monkey aspect of
it right
yeah it's kind of it's just demeaning
too i would just feel bad
i just i respect you too much though
yeah well i appreciate that but
i will put gorilla glue in my hair for
that yeah to be fair
he was the one that threw that out there
you kind of like jokingly asked last
night
like how much would it cost to do that
and immediately
okay okay okay what about if we also put
it on your pubes
oh god what
uh yeah
yeah i brought the greatest bird i have
the greatest beard but um
did you say you have the greatest beard
i said i don't know
and eyebrows just like
stop there why stop there because i feel
like that's different eyelashes
i'm just in your eyeball look i'll say
i'll do anything for a sub
anything anything damn huh a b
and do you care about watches no not
really
and ian i don't think so do you oh no
this is exactly jack might be the only
one that cares yeah
we have to find out what you guys like
and then humiliate you for that
all right let's bring a big nick all
right big nick
you're coming oh my god oh my god my
girl is [ __ ] i just i
always start the day with coffee and it
ruins my gerd i wish i just wouldn't
drink the coffee
how am i supposed not to drink the
coffee you know what might be the
solution
eat a little something with it and i
don't know your brother told me that
big nick how are you guys let me um give
me one moment i want to
dan can you move him over to the how do
i move yeah i'll take care of it oh i
have it here
i'm sorry um give me one sec i'm just
i'm pulling you up here buddy
appreciate it god bless how have you
been i mean i haven't i haven't uh
haven't heard great man honestly uh
you know when this pandemic first
started it was kind of weird for all of
us
but i feel like as i kind of got locked
down a little more i was able to just
kind of
figure out life a little better and you
know i feel like i think a lot more
or i think a lot more efficiently when
i'm by myself
so pretty good year to be honest uh
how about you guys how's everything it's
good like you said you know the pandemic
is wild why is he chilling myself
oh yeah
hold on one sec uh uh nick
should i call you nick or big nick
anything is cool
okay i pinned it but why is it still
switching because you were pinned on the
program you were
seeing this the show stream and he was
on screen so you thought it was him
he's pinned now you're good yeah and i
don't want to show this [ __ ] on the top
or
are you showing i'm you're not gonna
nobody's gonna see that okay okay cool
big nick you found god i mean that's a
pretty big development sir
yes sir what would you say did some
research or what
yeah i did a little bit of research but
you you're representing big time with
the hat and the necklace and everything
is it jesus all day this is the only hat
that is like
curved that i could find and i got a
haircut recently
so i haven't posted about it yet so i'm
like trying to kind of
keep it right it's a big reveal yeah
you can see it a little bit so so nick
you used to be a big part of the vlog
squad i remember when i started watching
it you were
in almost every video you know yeah and
you reached out to me after
our last episode of frenemies
saying that um i guess
you wanted to supplement or correct some
of the information i had said
so first of all i guess i just would
like to ask you about the
you know what what did you what were
your thoughts on
on that epis last episode sure so
i know i watched the last episode um and
you know what i thought it was
i thought you had an interesting take on
it i don't think you were necessarily
wrong
about what you were saying the thing
that really kind of
um just made me be like all right i have
to go on and say something is
okay so i don't know if you guys have
tik tok but there's these like podcast
people who are really big on tick tock
and
they basically reacted to your podcast
and then they were basically making
jokes about
me saying like rest in peace a big nick
and i'm like dude like
why are these people coming for me like
no one even knows the full story and
i've been silent for a long time um
just because i wanted to like quote
unquote protect people but it's like
why am i gonna protect somebody when
like all these conspiracy theories are
being made around my name
uh you know and it's just like it's just
not really worth
not saying anything i've been really
quiet and i don't really like to get in
drama
or gossip um i'm not really like all for
that but i do want to clear my name
and i think it is really important that
i mentioned some stuff
on what led to me not wanting to be a
part of that uh whole group anymore
okay fair enough yeah i mean i've i've
always been a f
like i enjoyed doing the vlogs you know
i always liked you
so i never thought bad of you i just i i
don't know why i never knew why you left
the
the group honestly i didn't follow it
that that closely david's
vlog but um based so
trisha describes being there as like
kind of toxic would you describe it that
way
uh it is i think she has her own agenda
but
she's not entirely wrong with all the
stuff she says but she's not
always accurate it's like 50 50. but
it is kind of like a cult yeah it's like
a high school vibe
very cultish like vibe and you can kind
of feel it like even when i would like
film with people afterwards i would come
home
so drained like just mentally and it
wasn't necessarily i mean maybe it was
because some of the stuff they were
saying but like it was just really the
energy in the room like it just felt
like really demonic energy i couldn't
explain it at the time and
i didn't really know what it was until i
kind of did some more soul searching and
i'm like
oh okay like this is what it was you
know but i always remember talking to my
friends like
afterwards like yo i gotta get out of
this i got i can't do this you know that
was me behind the scenes the whole time
and um i was just constantly stressing
about
like how do i escape from this like this
is you know people have branded me with
this
whole uh you know vlog squad thing like
how do i get out of it because i really
didn't want any part of it i mean
i'm friends with like i've been friends
with david jason all of them and like i
love jason i know
trisha has like a different opinion on
jason jason's always been like cool with
me
i don't know about other people and um
even david like i still love david i
mean we talk from time to time
but um you know as far as the rest of
the group
uh you know they gossip behind your back
they um have the superiority complex of
like
i'm better than you and you can just
feel it in the room without them having
to say it
and i think it kind of got to that point
because
um i was allowing and i did allow it and
that's partially my fault
um david to like disrespect me in the
videos and so then everybody else just
got the notion like
oh okay like you know we can disrespect
big nick too like it's
because our master does it you know that
was kind of like the whole
vibe and it just felt like a huge cult
of
just bad energy and i didn't want any
part of it and from an entertainment
perspective they do a great job of
entertaining i mean the numbers
obviously prove that right
they're one of the biggest groups on
social media
um but just because you're popular
doesn't mean you're like a good person
you know what i mean you give a lot of
popular people and i'm not
like comparing these people to these
other extreme people but like
let's just bring up an extreme example
like hitler he had a lot of followers
but like that doesn't mean he was a good
person
i think people like i think people just
like really
um and i'm not trying to compare to
hitler like
what is david done dude holy [ __ ] i'm
just trying to i'm just trying to like
put things into perspective like
just because someone's popular doesn't
mean that they're
always like a good person sure of course
of course um
and like i i like i don't want to be
like extreme i just wanted to bring up
an extreme example
to get my point across oh yeah um but
yeah so how many
jews has david killed can you confirm or
deny
i actually really do like i still like
david i mean
david's always gonna have like a soft
spot at my heart
uh we met up on vine back when i was big
on vine
and um you know he hit me up he reached
out through alex actually
and we linked up we made a couple vines
and this is when i was like super big on
blind back in the day and
you know our friendship was great we
started collaborating making more
content
and um you know at the end of the day i
don't really care about numbers
at all it doesn't matter to me um but
i'm just putting things into perspective
like
at the time i was like almost three
times the size of david on vine
so i was kind of like collaborating with
him not because i had anything to gain
out of it
but because i just genuinely liked the
guy and um
you know so do you think that he outgrew
do you feel at
all like maybe he used you to grow and
then got bigger than you and then kind
of left you behind
um i definitely think uh he used
uh the content that we made yeah like i
wouldn't say he
used me but he definitely used my
situation
for content and then um didn't really
like
um i don't know how to explain this
didn't really like
uh like help me progress at all i don't
expect help from anybody but he didn't
like help me
progress in the way that other people
could and
and i was just like you know what that's
fine like you know maybe there's
people who are doing better than me who
are more favored than me and that's
completely okay like
at the end of the day i'm not like this
beggar that's like begging somebody oh
please help me you know what i mean like
just social media is what it is i was on
my own before social media
and i continued to do my own solo thing
but i just noticed like
um yeah i felt like there was an unfair
treatment in behavior and i already
vocalized this with him like
we had a long talk uh december of
last year not even well last last year
and um yeah i just told him everything
and like
uh you know i basically told him like
yeah man this is how i feel
and he apologized and you know he was
mature enough to apologize to me
but um i'm coming on here like i said
just to clear
my name so what are you calling your
name what are you getting your name on
i'm just clearing my name of like uh
like i said the sync podcast or whatever
they like
posted a tick tock saying like i got
dropped from the vlog squad or something
when really it was the exact opposite
um like i said i was stressing on how i
could get out of it
and how i could be in the content less
because it also got to a point where
people would recognize me in public
and then they would make jokes like
about me and i'm like
dude like i don't know you this is weird
you know so
like what kind of jokes like just like
making fun of my height and stuff
just because david did it and um yeah so
so let me let me it seems like they were
it seems like your time in the vlog
squad they made you the butt of the joke
a lot
and yeah that probably started to bother
you you know and and like it's like
everybody all of a sudden not giving you
any respect
right exactly and it was just weird
because it's like dude like
i'm coming from a perspective like i
collaborated with you
when i was you know essentially bigger
online and like this is how i get
treated like
you're like trashing me over something i
can't control and as a kid i used to
struggle a lot like
with depression about you know who i was
and stuff until
uh recently and um i used to struggle a
lot like i would even be
as a kid i would be like you know
complain to my mom like mom like
why is this like why am i going through
this stuff like why am i short blah blah
blah and so he kind of like
with that content like opened up that
clothes
and like i just didn't like it and
people like are coming up with these
conspiracy theories that i got
like kicked out and it's like dude if
you had to go through that
and you were like made fun of something
you couldn't control and like millions
of people are
like we're talking football stadiums on
football stadiums are like
all cheering that on and i'm actually
kind of disappointed that like
people did cheer it on even though
obviously i allowed it and like i'm
fully responsible for allowing it um i
was just kind of disappointed that like
uh nobody really thought it was wrong
you know i haven't seen
people recognize me and say like sorry
to interrupt you a little bit i had some
people recognize me and be like hey like
why are they so mean to you and i would
just be the type of guy to protect these
people and be like
oh you know it's all good it's all jokes
but really like no i was hurt too
of course like hearing people ask me
that i'm like dang like
people like people get it you know so
yeah i was just i'm just glad that
chapter is over
and i wish them the best honestly like i
have no
hatred uh i don't want to seek any
vengeance or anything like that that's
not where i'm coming from
i'm just here to kind of tell it how it
is and so you when you left the group
how did how did it play out
when you told david like yo i gotta get
out he asked you why and did you say
like
honestly it's just a toxic environment
for me with all the jokes about
about my dwarfism
is that right yeah yeah so yeah i
basically told him like dude i don't
want to make these jokes anymore
and he was just like okay like that's
fine like he was chill about it whatever
um and i knew by saying that i wasn't
gonna be in the content anymore
but after that yeah like i just because
i didn't want to like get made fun of
like it was just like all right like i
respect that bro and then that was that
and it wasn't like oh that sounds [ __ ]
up i gotta actually interject
you said yo i just i don't want you to
make fun of my height anymore
and that was and he's like okay well
there's no point of having you in the
vlogs then
right that was kind of the that doesn't
seem very
that doesn't sound very good locally
said that you know what i mean but that
was for sure the vibe
did david ever did david ever make any
statement on you
or what happened or no like there was no
statement made about me and that's why
i'm coming on here today
to tell people the truth because none of
these people wanted to shut down these
like conspiracy theories
because there's a lot of people who are
saying theories about me
and it's just like dude like i don't
like just leave me alone
you know like i mean i know i don't
think i don't mean to
like uh add salt to the wound but i feel
like
he should he also has the responsibility
to say something and clear it out too
well
and that's why like i said i'm on here
today i think nick you're trying to be
really respectful and mature about it
and
and not like uh hold resentment which is
nice
but at the end of the day i mean you
were in this guy's videos
big fodder for so long and when you say
yo just don't make fun of my height
anymore cause like
you know it's a lot to get the vibe like
okay well you're useless to me i mean
that's kind of adding insult to injury
to be like
well that's that's actually all you're
here for is just to be the butt of the
joke i mean i don't know that that's
painful yeah but like i knew that
i knew that after a while because i i
was confusing
like i was confused at first on where
the friendship was going it was kind of
like a snowball effect
where like you see this the the snowball
about to hit you and then it's getting
bigger and bigger
and then you get to a point of
realization where you're like oh wait
these people only hang out around me
to put me down and feel better about
themselves yeah and i was like dude
this is like a hot like and i've never i
you know i'm so thankful to god i never
got bullied in school but this was the
first time i ever felt some sort of like
bullying high school scenario and i was
like dude and
and these people aren't even in high
school anymore they're in their 20s
30s like what i thought we
matured past that you know so it was
just kind of like
it's just kind of weird for me you know
so coming out of that situation where
you
were were you kind of hoping that you
could continue doing the vlogs with them
with taking the short stuff out were you
kind of like damn like i don't know i
can imagine that was painful coming out
of that situation
yeah i mean like look at the end of the
day i like making content with
people and i let a lot of stuff slide
and i tolerated a lot of stuff
and i would have been open to filming um
with david despite the short jokes and
stuff but like
i don't like and i don't want to say
this to like cause any like conflict or
anything i just didn't like filming
around
majority of those people um just because
uh there was a lot of like you could
feel the uh
the toxicity in the air right and like i
said i'm not like
but don't you think don't you blame
david for that because that's kind of
what i wanted like
because like he's the king he's the ring
leader he's the one that sets the tone
so don't you believe i'll like worship
him yeah if everybody's just trying to
play around i mean isn't it david's
fault if he's creating that environment
and also when you said that it was like
a cult i mean every cult has a leader
yeah and clearly it's him
ultimately he's the one that sets the
tone yeah he's the one that yeah
sets the environment for everyone right
and that's what it was he said the
environment that like
it was okay to make fun of me and then
like everybody up but you know what i
gotta give a shout out to scotty because
like
he was one of the only people that
really like stuck up for me and like
said like hey i don't like what you know
the jokes that you're making about
really well good guy
he vocalized he didn't like it that's
nice honestly i gotta give props to
scotty he was probably
one of the most mature people in that
conversation and even jason's
like at a certain level did stick up for
me and like
you know like i do like some of those
people in there but majority of people
just were like
yeah you know what like we're just gonna
do this we're gonna make fun of nick
because our
our leader is doing it you know trisha
described the
situation where she's like they asked
her to stay in the car because they
like she wasn't she'd like fallen out of
favor with david
did you see situations like that play
out in your time with them where he was
like you stay back you come with
i never i never saw them like
um dictate what i had to do and uh
they're not like
forceful uh like dictators like that
i don't see that happening but
they were definitely like they obviously
don't like to be
in drama which makes sense because it's
not really good for anyone's brand
and when trisha was kind of like doing
all that stuff
online it did cause a lot of stress
for them at the time because it's just
like they've never been in drama before
and now this is like the
the first like scandal or whatever you
want to call it right so
but i never saw any behavior like that
no
so how did they respond to trish's thing
because she said because you were there
with them at the time
because she was saying like that um
you know she was feeling suicidal and
that david
was not taking her seriously and was
encouraging
jason to cheat on her and all that stuff
do you have any insights all that um
i don't have any insight on that i
wasn't there for
majority of the the time that she's
referring to
and there are like other sides
of the story too that i was present for
um and yeah like it that's kind of a
tricky thing because like
i i can feel her on the whole like you
know
feeling suicidal part i mean for a long
time like
i felt like worthless being in those
videos like i was like dude why am i
even like
here like what's the point of my
existence because i was just treated
like
this uh like this uh punching bag right
like everyone's just
uh joking about me like mocking me then
the fans in public are doing the same
and like i had a good long look in the
mirror and like
i was like wow i'm like really depressed
like and that was kind of my
um signal to be like all right dude like
i i realize right then and there
like followers fame money none of this
stuff
is worth it if i'm getting to the point
where like i don't even want to live
yeah you know and so i had like and
honestly i'm kind of glad
i went through that because it kind of
broke
in a way like the way i viewed success
right as a kid i
i got big online and i just equated
success with money followers
fame and then i got to the point where
i'm like look i'm gaining all this stuff
and i'm more depressed than i ever was
before
yeah so that was kind of like a big um
uh i would say like twist in my life
that i actually didn't need
i didn't go through that because it
actually made me
um more mature i feel like now that's
good
well you know i think the reason why
dave and his crew doesn't like the drama
because it's like a crack in the armor
and like he
he creates this illusion where it's all
laughs and it's all fun right
and everybody looks at it like this is
like a perfect life where everyone's
having fun and stuff
but when you understand that like
actually it's toxic and maybe they're
bowling people and may
the people who are there are actually
miserable because they're just [ __ ]
working all the time and not thinking
about the consequences of what they do
i think that that might he's it's just
it breaks the illusion that they're
casting because like
you know like when they're making fun
like everybody's forced to laugh real
big you know when there's like a joke
i mean you know what they're not
forced to they actually all do it in
synchronized harmony it's so weird isn't
it
it's like he's not like it's like almost
they're all they all have like a
queue like oh yeah let's laugh at this
like there's ac i
sometimes laughs will be um like redone
and you know you can detach the audio
and put that under the clip
you know and pretend like it's a laugh
but most of the time no they will all
laugh
in synchronized perfect harmony that's
cool
oh you mean they didn't even need to
edit they were actually
oh they didn't do it yeah it's like they
all just have a cue to do it
yeah yeah so and yeah it's just like
it's like i said it kind of goes back to
the cult thing yeah
and so i was watching all this and
obviously i was a part of it
and but like something in my spirit was
just like dude you gotta get out
like this is not normal and and i'm
thinking well why would i get like you
don't have those conversations with
yourself like well why would i get out
like
this is the most popular group on the
internet yeah yeah yeah
but like oh whatever was telling me to
get out man like
i honestly think it was god right so
yeah i'm just really glad that
that i'm out of there and i feel like
free almost like i feel like i've
escaped from prison in a way
wow so it feels kind of good but i just
don't like it when people
um like come up with those like i said
conspiracy theories about oh why did
big nick get kicked out of the vlog
squad oh maybe it's because of this
oh maybe it's because it's like dude let
me i'm just gonna say something about
this oh yeah
it's not okay too that no one else said
anything to clear your name either
yeah that was best and i was hoping
there's two parties here that
yeah and i do feel i feel like david
kind of owes you an apology for
not only allowing people to speculate
and stuff but i mean
look he enabled a really toxic workplace
situation for you that it's not just
workplace it continues outside to the
real world when right
fans would come and make fun of you in
real life like yeah because
that's just that's just i mean you
deserve respect as much as anybody there
and i feel like and i appreciate that
and honestly that does mean a lot
because like
that's all i just wanted to hear is like
dude you deserve respect
just like everyone else yeah like the
fact that i couldn't even like
get that respect it's like dude what is
the point of all of this you know like
it just didn't make any sense and the
other thing too is like i would always
be on eggshells walking on eggshells
because
i would hear them like talk badly about
each other um when like another person
wasn't there like they would make fun of
alex
they would say like oh like one day alex
is gonna come in here and like shoot all
of us and they were all like making fun
of him
because like alex just wanted to live
like a normal simple life and they all
just called him crazy
and like so i would just hear that
gossip and i'd be like dude what are
they saying about
me when i'm not here you know like and
uh there were other times too where i'm
not gonna name names but like other
people in that group
because i knew a girl that was hooking
up with one of them
and she would overhear conversations of
people in that group talking badly about
david when they weren't around or when
david wasn't around and i'm like whoa
like that kind of was like they're even
talking they're even gossiping about the
leader
like that's crazy to me because it's
like oh they're for sure saying stuff
about me when i'm not around in their
group chat or
you know when they're hanging out with
each other and that was just another big
indicator for me to like get out you
know
just seems like you said really toxic
and just like paranoid looking over your
shoulder wondering what people really
think about you i mean it seems wild
yeah a lot of them are probably to
unfollow me after this or
or whatnot but like at the end of the
day man i'm speaking my truth like
you're not saying that you're not doing
this so
you're not saying anything here that it
doesn't sound like
a normal point of view i mean you
what you're saying makes sense to me if
anyone is i'm following you because of
that then
well [ __ ] them yeah exactly but you know
it's like i feel like at a certain point
you're just you're totally justified i
mean you've got to say something for
yourself you know what i mean that's
what i'm saying dude like and i was
debating even like
doing this because like i said i don't
i don't like my brand to be like
surrounded with
like drama but this isn't really drama
you're being really mature and nice
about it you're definitely
you're i don't i don't think you're i
don't think
i don't see it that way personally but i
do feel like you know
i sense that you still have some closure
right to
on this situation because it was kind of
it seems like it was kind of traumatic
for you
yeah i actually did like have that like
i said and david did apologize to me
like
um i did kind of have that like last
in-person conversation with him
a long time ago and i think it was like
closure and whatnot and like he did
apologize like
he did seem genuinely sorry you know and
so
i just want to put that out there like
you know he was mature enough and man
enough to like
hear me out and understand yeah but he
never but it's like he apologized but
then he cut you out of his life
right uh yeah i mean i guess i wasn't
filming with them as much anymore
because
they didn't have like someone to make
fun of and i found that like i said very
weird
because it's like why do you feel the
need to bring yourselves above me and
putting me down for something i can't
control
you have a good point too it's like
every this is supposed to be like a
wholesome vlog and everybody who's
watching this is like
silently agreeing with this bullying
that's happening it's just super weird
where everyone's like this is fine
maybe it's because they see you laughing
along that they think oh he's just
confident he's just it doesn't get to
him you know
yeah yeah it would really like it really
tore me down for a long time and like
uh i like picked myself back up and i
and nobody knew what i was going through
behind the scenes and like i said i
didn't say anything for a long time
because i just wanted to like protect
other people but like i said i'm like
i'm not gonna silence myself or not
speak the truth
to protect people who had no problem
like making fun of me for no reason you
know
yeah yeah well i'm glad you're out of
there
it sounds like you're a good spot
honestly it's like a breath
of fresh air man and you know i'm really
really glad
that um i had that opportunity to kind
of distance myself and it was a long and
gradual process like even when i still
was allowing the jokes like
i would like not want to go and film
in certain places because i was like
look if i can gradually
appear in these videos less and less and
less then like
people will already get the point that
like i'm not trying to do it anymore
and you know at the end of the day like
i just want to do my own thing
build my own brand i'm a very simple guy
like i don't
i don't need to be around like a bunch
of big crowds doing a bunch of crazy
things like i'm perfectly content with
just
going solo and doing my own thing and
why is it that you wanted to like taper
out instead of just quitting i'm curious
um because i wanted to kind of fade so
here's why because if i slowly faded
away
people wouldn't like suspect anything
wrong
on either of our ends and they would
just think oh it was like maybe a
you know it was just natural when in
reality it was i was kind of just like
plotting like how do i make this look as
natural as possible
so yeah that's tough man well
um your key i mean you're still making
content on big nick
yeah man i'm still making content uh you
know filmed a youtube video this week
i'm still filming like
videos everywhere to be honest and the
best thing about this whole
covet thing and and being like a social
media personality is that you can do
everything
from home and that's just what i keep
planning on doing and
um yeah i'm just really excited for this
new journey in my life
i mean it's been a new journey for a few
months now but uh
i'm just really glad to finally like not
be associated
with like the vlog squad anymore and
obviously people are gonna like look at
old videos and stuff
and um and sure whatever i made those
videos it's not like i'm gonna ask him
to delete all of them you know
but uh i'm just really glad like like i
said do you wish you would get rid of
all the videos with you in it where
they're
goofing on you um you know
it would be cool but i'm not gonna ask
him to do that
because at the end of the day like
and you know as weird as it sounds like
it's his content and um i just don't
want to intrude on
like policing his content it was already
said it's already done people have
already seen it
there's really no point and i just don't
want to be that guy that's like
you have to take this down yeah yeah no
i understand you're super polite
obviously and
i can tell you're you want to tread
carefully but
i understand what you mean too it's like
you know at the same time you don't you
don't want that stuff
online yeah i appreciate you having me
on man and
like i said i've been watching you guys
like since like my beginning
days of being a content creator and i
really love your guys's videos thank you
man thank you i appreciate that
like i love how vila like over the years
kind of became more open to like
you know being a part of the videos and
like it was probably a little
awkward at first for you right like
cause you were
you know i know i know breaking out of a
cold is quote unquote is probably one of
the hardest things someone can do so
good job taking care of yourself and
looking out for yourself and ultimately
you know getting out of that situation
so good work man
i'm sorry i'm sorry you went through all
that it sounds like it was really really
really nobody
i really feel like like i said i i had
to go through that yeah and if i could
go back and do it again
i mean i probably would because as weird
as it sounds it kind of
strengthened me mentally a lot and
i have a really good outlook and
perspective on
how to carry myself in the future and so
i feel like we do
go through everything for a reason and
that's why i'm not like
really resentful or hateful about any of
this like i'm just
it's like look this is what happened and
this is i'm gonna keep moving
you know going forward so god bless
big night and youtube twitter
anything else you're up to uh yeah
youtube twitter
instagram tick tock big nick everywhere
yeah man your boy is everywhere
yeah i appreciate that man all right
thanks man i appreciate you calling in
and sharing your story
for sure man love you guys take care all
right bye dude bye
i like him i like big nick
so toxic in there it's crazy
he's trying so hard to be nice too but i
can understand yeah he doesn't want to
start yeah
he's trying to just move past everything
but i just want to put it behind
him yeah i it's funny because when i i
never followed his
vlogs closely but i always thought i
thought big nick was cool
you know doing his thing i wasn't
following it either
closely but i know what it was like i've
i've seen
you know videos here and there obviously
that sounds horrible it sounds so tough
i mean it really reminds me of like
bullying in high school it's way more
complicated though it's way worse
yeah it's way more complicated worse
because it's like like a thousand times
the problem is like first of all there's
millions of people watching but also
it's like you're getting something
really
um valuable and tangible from it which
is like the views and the subscribers
and the attention
so like he said it's so hard to balance
that with
the negative and to rationalize leaving
yeah is really you know tough
i do think it's important for people to
know though like
behind the laughter the tears that's the
story that's his
that's his uh the name of his
documentary behind the laughter
you guys going to laugh and tune with me
there you go get that down we'll work on
that
thanks dan
maybe you're a david you're like a david
stan aren't you
i feel like this is a bad time to be one
but uh yeah i like david
but again because you said well you said
you [ __ ] like when we talked about it
with trisha
you said that you felt like you could
mount a good defense
so i'm just curious if there's a flip
side to look at this that i'm not seeing
i feel like i'd like to better prepare
my argument okay you've got to
internalize a little bit sure
yeah okay no problem got arguments for
everyone
arguments are you saying that big nick
is not being i'm just kidding
son of a lawyer i'm just kidding your
honor at this time i am not prepared to
make a statement
correct um
as a way of kind of transitioning out of
that um we've had a lot of super chats
yeah go ahead i just saw one in
particular
i wanted to read off about the weird
russians um
uh they donated uh russian rubles so i'm
assuming they're shout out
shout out to the family uh arseney
sorry if i said your name wrong i think
the author of that channel tries to
catch the wave of redneck bloggers doing
weird things in russia
it has become pretty popular in russia
google google oleg
mongol oh my god someone also sent me a
uh
they did a quick translation oh really
really
i just sent it to you oh cool vladimir
putin
it just says vladimir putin
okay here we go we got a translation
here we go thank you ian
um interesting so it says preparing to
shoot avatar five
oh no no no
they're doing an avatar recreation that
explains
everything oh that makes so much more
sounds
from what i can tell this video is just
a joke about the fact that they are look
like movie characters but they did it so
many times
and they're so drunk and they're so out
of it exactly
he's well made up this purple guy here
is my favorite
no not my normal hue he says very
drunkenly
luke lucas uh you alright this one is a
little green
tell me honestly am i a mule yes
so mystery solved
thank you dear listener yeah it does um
it does now that they pointed that out
it does remind me of um you know that
whole set of uh
weird guys on instagram uh from florida
that uh all gas no breaks he's like
buddies oh yeah that's down there it
seems like like
joker yes exactly right it's kind of
joker man they're like trying to be like
the russian version of that so wait what
was the name you told me to google oled
mongolian mongol mongol yeah
oh like mongol
jesus olaf
get new subscribers oleg
yeah and then mongol mongol okay i got
it
all right i don't know what this is this
is just this was part of their message
so this is the king of this [ __ ]
apparently oh
my goodness this is their hero this is
totally okay
okay this is their absolutely totally
get the same vibes
yeah as all those florida guys yeah this
guy seems like more of a legend to be
honest
this guy's the real deal huh
okay so it's not as weird as i feared
which kind of is a relief
yeah it's just a couple of drunk guys
screwing around so i'm kind of relieved
by that fair enough
this guy seems interesting look at this
shooting avatar that's so funny
yeah wow they're just shooting avatar
look at this bro this is a serious
situation over here
look at this that's what's going on over
there can you get rid of the little mini
ian at the bottom of your screen
just drag it off yeah there you go
okay anything else what's illuminating
also got a lot of uh chats and donations
um people want you to watch this
sleepwalking girl from tick tock
give it here
a lot of people are wondering do you
think it's fake do you think it's real
okay good i'd love to give my opinion on
this i love it i love
it we love it
oh i did see this on my feed i i didn't
think much about it i
okay the spices on the top and
so obviously you can't tell if it's real
or not but it's possible that it's real
people do sleepwalk after the stories
ian's told us
who better to say than ian right do you
think
i think maybe some of them are real or
started real but she's getting like
such crazy engagement i've had this sent
to me so many times that
she might be exaggerating uh yeah
oh the fact that that makes sense the
fact that she's out in the front yard is
kind of
wild i notice she's always like she goes
in the front yard but she just stays
right in frame of the camera let's say
that it's edited that way but i don't
know
well dude this says 18 million views
what i mean yeah but my ass is getting
18 million views i'm
he's just watching her i mean that's
what you're supposed to do right ian
yeah you're not supposed to engage too
much so what do you do when you see all
this going on you just enjoy the show i
guess
her poor husband is just sitting there
oh my god sam literally did that with me
last night
really i was trying to dig a hole well
maybe she's the right person to give us
an answer can we ask her what she thinks
if it's real or fake well
like when i sleepwalk yeah my my speech
is so
unintelligible like it's not words it's
been it it's very quick i'll sleepwalk
i'll do an activity and i'll stop
i don't know though this could be super
super extreme it could be real so
i literally punched a hole in the wall
so it's like
yeah this one has 52 million views you
were digging a hole i was like sitting
on the rug and i was like
trying to dig something god damn she's
just like staying away
from you just watching yeah because she
says whenever she
whenever she engages with me i get
really grumpy
because i feel kind of like like
embarrassed in a way
because i i then realize the
ridiculousness of what i'm doing
and then she's caught me doing it and
then i just feel really
like kind of ashamed and stupid
especially because i'm half awake
so i think sleepwalkers get agitated
quickly but this woman seems very calm
when she's being interacted with
this one this one this one has 52
million uh views
it's pretty funny yeah i mean either way
it's pretty funny
so big she says about herself
i think it's probably half half yeah
there's a journal of truth
right i agree with that it started real
probably like she probably really does
some of it
but maybe it's all real though i mean
i'm you know it could all be where
yeah who knows but
well we yeah let me go back to our first
one i feel like that will give clues
because
her first one probably was real
and then when she saw the views i feel
like without knowing
ian i would probably wait she's already
popular fake
hold on she's she's getting millions of
views even before the street walking
turn this mannequin into winifred
sanderson so i busted my spooky booty
down to spirit hallway
she's popular on tick tock before the
sleepwalking thing yeah
really popular i mean these all have
millions of views
oh so what does that tell you is that a
clue
and then she's an entertainer she's
definitely an entertainer that kind of
puts it in a new light doesn't it yeah
yeah let's find the first one and get
really get to the bottom of this
but yeah she's very popular on tick tock
so here's the first one 24 million it
was a mega hit
and then all of a sudden her whole
channel turns into sleepwalking videos
i'm calling it fake maybe that first
one's real let's watch the first one and
see how real 24 million
welcome to sleepwalking with me
seems
see this one seems more erratic and
weird this one
actually to me seems a little more
realistic so maybe this first one was
real and it got
super viral and then she started faking
a bunch more
see that one was so much weirder than
the other ones yeah i think so this was
the first one the one mega viral oh wait
no here was one earlier
oh wait no she has several i'm sorry
we're wrong so wait
wait that wasn't the first one so here
this might be the first one
you guys love my sleepwalking videos oh
so what the [ __ ] do i know
i can't possibly guess which one's first
yeah if the thumb doesn't i'm out
i'm saying 50 50 on this one guys
straw poll anyone
there was one other there was a big
donor
so this hairspray girl's not responding
zach oh really
is that what's happening she's not
answering well it's two o'clock she said
she would be available at two right so
right so i think i still believe someone
donated a 69.69
they said uh i'm a pizza guy i pulled up
to a guy's place
after dark was blasting out my car zach
started slamming the yoko ono sound bite
the customer gave me the shittiest look
and i did not get a tip oh oh
no you really back what you doing
we owe that guy money i think we should
refund it yeah why are you paying yeah
it's just what can you do i mean that's
music i mean who are they the judge
that's that's
that's an acclaimed artist yeah
how dare they
anything else do we want to um
do our little meme with the code mikko
oh yeah is she still streaming i was
gonna i promised her i was gonna donate
so let's do this let's open code mikko
she was on our last episode she's the uh
youtuber huge on twitch she's coming
here having her come back
right now she is still live oh wow so
why i put a link to her channel in your
doc oh jinx is that
it's so weird that it doesn't show up i
just you know you think that will come
up
don't ask discord i got it so um
i promised her i was going to donate 200
and um ask her for feed pics
so let's do it so i'll hopefully she
sees it i don't know
i think yeah she's doing an interview so
she might miss it well
she gonna miss 200 asking for feed picks
you better not
hmm so go dan can you use my credit card
to donate
uh i i have it in your dock and it's all
set up on your computer already logged
in
ready to go wait what you want me to do
it i
thought you wanted to send a message so
how do i don't even know how to do this
work work so i go
go to the top of your dock and there's a
link that says oh it's in my document
yeah
um it's in the script
scripted i'm pretty sure okay
donation like okay you really want me to
do this live on my own
while i'm streaming well you don't just
don't put it on your name
h3 podcast it's just kind of slow do it
live
tip message show your feet
and toes please okay as promised
the pro the thing is she showed her feet
before in shoes but what you're saying
we want to see the toes
we want to see the toes the lumpy little
toes show toes
i want to talk about feet right
shoulders
okay 200 we're sending it
paypal check out and so i guess
it's exciting you got to watch this
carefully
yeah you guys let us know because
there's a lot going on in our stream so
hopefully she notice senpai notices uh
senpai notices me
people are spamming the chat saying
we're watching in show toes so
okay good okay so anyway 200
was sent to her as promised
oh it just said show toes can i spam i'm
logged in so here i'm going to get
i don't want to ruin her stream right
she does have an interview
but this is exciting we're going to get
to see her toes
hopefully she prepared for this she knew
i was coming you have a very nice fit
body oh [ __ ] again what did i walk in on
nice fit buddy i heard you the first
time
i saw your boob nice
they're nuts you're welcome
wow
yeah i love all like the camera
switching and everything too it's so
brilliant she seems very
um focused so
let's check back in just make sure to
let us know when she acknowledges the uh
the toad don't know so that's two
hundred dollars to uh
code mikko toes in the chats baby
those toes in the chat
wait for that so until then i do want to
stick around for the gorilla spray
girl that's really important to me
but we have a ton of do you know so in
china
china they have a new covet test for
high risk people elo
that's more accurate really do you have
any guess how it's very exciting
guess how it's performed
you have any guess no cut away when the
butt comes out
you can show this part but i'll so
i mean it's just a mannequin but it's
pretty graphic where it's pretty graphic
it's anatomically uh
accurate i got my finger on the button
so here let me take it off the screen
so just give you guys an idea and then
eli you can continue to watch with my
computer
ela you narrate all right
pants are being removed
it's a nice butthole the butt is
revealed and then here's the hey there's
a ball
there's a ball sack bro can you notice
that there's a ball shot yes
and then he's showing the swabs he
smells it at one point
does he no you're kidding
okay so it's i mean literally like the
swamp test
but in the butt yeah apparently far more
accurate
it's far more accurate according to this
disgusting
according to this the virus sticks
around the butthole
much longer than the
sinus but they did say unfortunately
that
it cannot be used widely as the
technique was quote
not convenient definitely
that's an appropriate uh description
any code miko update she's pro go to
stream okay let's go
come on hurry here we go here we go i
don't want to miss it
she's talking about it i don't want to
miss it come on come on dick's out boys
wait what what else yeah you asked what
mike i think she's offered no
200 bucks and i missed it
i bro what did she say baby good
fun i think she just clarified and said
that it's just a joke
because chat was it's not just a joke
what the [ __ ]
i thought she'd be ready for this
well somebody will clip it i'm sure
yeah but i guess she's not down may
already be clipped
check the check the clips ian on her
twitch channel
there's probably already a clip of it it
doesn't sound like it was much
but i had to keep my promise to her
promises made promises kept yeah
all right well then you know as we wait
for gorilla glue
you'll watch this and you tell me what
you think about this
he just disappeared man
oh that's awesome there's like a [ __ ]
there's a few frames where he really
just here let me put in slow motion
there's a few frames where he really
just continues on without his board
look at this
it's awesome wow it's just floating
actually it looks better normal i have
to say
yeah it does it looks like he doesn't
even move
good [ __ ] bro well done sir
i have a lot of great little failed
vlogs touched by no videos
oh i haven't seen that okay i mean
i love the scooter [ __ ]
here we go dudes at the atm oh
dude she didn't even slow down oh my god
didn't even slow down
just ran that was like a hit and run
oh my god mobility mary is
taking oh no they have to lift her off
because she virgins [ __ ] bend him
down
the whole city is coming to the rescue
oh no
stop going forward so the question is
still pressing it yeah this whole time
i think you need a license to operate
those things man those are dangerous
okay this was my favorite touchpoint
video of the uh of the week okay
dodge welcome to ether boy
douche this is the mayor
of some of the genevieve well we're
going to vote
he seemed shocked when he hit the guy
but at the same time
i love how he pushes him over
did he do it intentionally or was it an
accident
he seems surprised though when he makes
an impact
the other thing is that he doesn't try
to stop his fall at all
he just embraces it as his punishment
well we're going to vote
this has been your touch point oh moment
nice
nice what what todd's plan i'll say
about this what would daniel todd say
about this
nice let's throw it into slow motion and
analyze let's we gotta go back and
analyze
i've never watched a second of tosh
point oh
you're missing out i thought it was an
american classic it's very popular yeah
never
never yeah here comes the biker in slow
motion
and he's going right straight with our
kamikaze for the mayor
apparently he uh gave him one too many
parking tickets
here he comes coming in slow motion and
not not gonna pause right before impact
how am i dying
not good [ __ ] notice the mayor's face
that blur like you could definitely see
his face by the way
he's like bro and then
he just he just takes this fall bro he
doesn't even try to stop himself
you gotta love it folks this segment was
brought to you by
mountain dew do the do they always do
they have like sponsored videos by like
this one is brought to you by cool ranch
doritos mountain dew
mountain dew ranch
now right nothing from gorilla glue eh
zach
she's not answering the phone come on
jessica come on
man come on how does she know that i
don't have what she needs to help her
i just not answering yesterday when i
spoke to her last night she was all
geared up ready for it and people said
she's in the er
holy [ __ ] what are you guys just making
that up oh check her tick tock
well i mean maybe av said people in the
chat said it buddy let me check her
out it's not being confirmed well let me
see if there's any updates on our tick
tock
i went to her instagram i didn't see
anything i'm checking the news i didn't
see anything
well apparently she's had it for a month
so i mean this ain't neuter
this ain't her first rodeo this isn't my
first rodeo
where the f is my tom selleck what do
you think pretty good
okay cool thanks no problem
i'm trying to find it in the [ __ ]
document
where the f
twitter check her twitter y'all get on
that twitter
you know what
you really can't find it in the doc no
it's not here and then they're saying
she's also an instagram she apparently
posted
recently something or commented
it's what do you what dog do you look
it's right here jessica
it's right up near the top
i got it all highlighted for you it's
there oh [ __ ] me okay thank you
so let's see tick-tock
let's see your latest update oh the
coconut
fail okay her twitter let's see
um god when i click the link it doesn't
do anything okay here we go so she's on
twitter
let's see seven hours ago at this point
i may just go to the nail salon and let
them file my head
that's not an update that's a good idea
but it's not an update
you guys check her instagram yeah
there's nothing on so
you guys are just [ __ ] with us [ __ ]
chat again [ __ ] chat
the [ __ ] do you know well i'm glad i saw
that tweet
come on man come on man let's get a look
at her hair before
oh yeah she ain't getting those somebody
said no she commented on our ig
19 minutes ago she is ignoring y'all
lmao
well she commented on our i mean i don't
know
they were wrong about it being on her
twitter oh you guys better stop it's
a love sentence it's in common wait yo
love got something y'all really [ __ ]
dropping the ball on this love is on
it yeah love is part of the team going
right that's true
this is from three hours ago she said
going to the er
okay fair enough i'm just saying
what
i guess the er is more important right
i guess her health is more important
than the h3 podcast
it's uh three hours ago going to the er
what are they gonna do for her
i guess they have some kind of solutions
they're like listen lady
there's nothing we can do thank you love
someone's paying attention around here
she said it hurts too much 25 minutes
ago where'd she say that
again in her comment section can you
show a screenshot
that's what i was fearing it must be
hurting [ __ ] that poor girl
i wonder what they can do about it
i gorilla glue said if you do
with a certain right mixture of alcohol
you can dissolve the glue
maybe at the hospital they'll they'll
know what to do oh my god
but i'm sure but i'm sure it's probably
a medical first for them
yeah that's going to be i guess she's
just going to work and stuff
well i mean if it hadn't been hurting i
guess and like you said it
doesn't really look wrong oh here we
have more updates from love
she says shave it off she says it is
glued flat to my head there is no way
for me to do that without slitting my
scalp oh my god
damn well hopefully i want that watch
zach
well it wouldn't be to his scalp i will
say that but
yeah what would it yeah i'd still do it
even if it was to your scalp i mean well
she must have really like caked that
[ __ ] yeah yeah she did she kicked it
on for sure oh
yeah she but yeah she's not answering
well i think she's at the hospital zach
yeah
well hopefully we can get an update from
her i'm curious how they get it
off yeah damn
that's i feel like that's the craziest
thing i've ever seen
well it was funny but now it's just i'm
concerned for her
right well what if she yeah okay
hopefully they can take it off
maybe she'll just have to shave her head
off but that's people are worried here
they're going
please find and help her going to er
help her pay or offer suggestions do
something go into er i'll help you pay
for anything just
call me just come on
coconut tea and tea tree oil did not
work i mean listen
i could just put you got to put alcohol
in it overnight it's not about
coconut oil some sort of solvent is the
only thing that's going to work
but that's the thing is skin like
putting anything that's going to
dissolve glue
on your skin is listen it's not going to
be good
it's not a it's not a good situation
it's not
you know what i mean
oh brother
i'll uh check in with her she ever yeah
just just check in with her periodically
we gotta we gotta get updates from i'm
concerned i need to know what happened
yeah
and also like we need to know what to do
for you when we do it to you yeah
also it's gonna happen
i don't think i can do it too zach i'm
frankly surprised that you're willing to
do that for a [ __ ] watch
well it's good to know that you're
willing to go that far for the watch now
now we got that like when we need
something really right
really well i'm willing to go willing to
go that far for the show
the watch is just the you know oh really
yeah what if i get you a cheaper one
yeah we got more
updates from a b what do we got here um
yeah what about a casio the one with the
calculator on it
that was our next no no
um someone said i feel the comments are
way cooler than a [ __ ] role
male or alcohol definitely alcohol mayo
mayo
is that a fan of the show don't put
[ __ ] mail for christ
god damn she says i'm going to the er
four hours ago
follow the guidelines gorilla glue
themselves have given you yeah
or straight to the air she says i'm
going to the er
okay well that's probably it's probably
better for her to go to the er than come
on our show
well i mean you know
prior live er calling would be pretty
cool yeah i mean she could be why isn't
she streaming the er visit that's epic
um someone said come see me today she
says beauty it hurt to touch
oh i feel bad
all right well that's that
mystery solved well
halfway solved we'll have to follow them
no we'll need a follow-up for sure
yeah i wonder if she's gonna show up
with like a bald head or what i feel
like that's gonna have to be what
happens
yeah i think she's gonna be like
straight up bald yeah which is i think
it's fine i think
well better than being having a chick
glued to your dome yeah
jeez somebody donate five dollars a
shout out to her hare's family
right shout out to her pubes
all right well i wanted to get your
your take on this guy i don't know if i
showed this to you either but
there's this guy who does jaw workouts
on tick tock that always shows up on my
home page and i can't tell if it's real
or face filter
i genuinely can't tell well if anything
it's genetics
if he's got it no no no no he shows
before and afters he chews on this
community he chews on this ball all day
like all day
to strengthen his jaw look at his jaw
that's not genetic it looks like surgery
come on come on so i think he's yeah
i think he got a surgery because if you
go he's i've seen before now you see the
yeah let me see that abby says his jaw
was like that when he was younger
because i've seen this is genetic
oh here's jawline at five-year-old
really i've never seen anyone with a jaw
like that
ever that's pretty there alright here he
is as a kid
oh yeah he's yeah he's right yeah so why
is he chewing he doesn't need to work
out it's just like that naturally
yeah are those photoshops
no
can you find a before and after because
i saw one of him where he was like had a
tiny jaw
and then here let me see here you here's
a third strap for you
for me for you it's for you i'm not
in the words of ice cube i got news for
you
i got news for you hey oh come on
ice don't do me like that
that's good just shortened to ice
because then you can't screw it up and
say the wrong one he looks like a
freaking
like he looks like a like a wii avatar i
hate to say that because it's like
fall back on it but he looks like a wee
avatar i feel like in this specific
video it looks so exaggerated i don't
know what happened here but in the
others
it's just he looks like the baba bowie
character yeah the film he's like
baba he looks like he's about to do it
bubba bowie
pretty interesting though right either
come on here's another thir strap for
you
like in this videos he doesn't look
weird like in that other one i don't
know he was exaggerating it there
damn bro it's the jawline for me though
i don't care about anything else
um i wish i could find that before and
after look at his jaw bruh
i think he's got the ability to
exaggerate it he's doing like
flexing i don't know what he's doing
yeah anyway he's always on my feet and
people are always like what the yeah
because i'm
fascinated by his videos i'm always
interacting with them
i just can't believe what i'm seeing and
i i'm just always like is this real or
what
look at his face
love said uh he saw a comment on the
disguise tick tock that if your jaw is
improperly positioned the exercise he's
doing could
uh damage your jaw joint repeated
application high levels of force could
displace damage or where the bone
cushion cartilage
down the jaw joints yeah that makes
sense because yeah people like dude
uh like oh here here here here here
january 2019
that doesn't mean anything hold on hang
the hold on the phone
wait for it wait for the big reveal
20 21 cartoon character bubba boy
2019 i don't know 2019 normal guy
not normal you're actually just um
really got something for this guy no no
2019
2021
yeah but did you guys see how hot he
looked
whoa calm down damn yeah i hey first of
all ab thank you for that because i do
think we should put a disclaimer that
this is not a healthy thing to do
yeah that's that was my first feeling
too like that's gotta be
not good for you oh someone a dentist
commented
you want to read that maybe
it says i work in dental i think he has
a very strong
i don't know how to pronounce this i'm
sorry messengers clenching muscles
and he can protrude them when he flexes
that's what i said
but probably from the result were the
result of exercising though not even a
doctor
this guy's my okay here's 2018. he's
doing his exercises
he's doing his exercises looks pretty
normal why are you still upset look
he's normal
baba all right are you not
fascinated by this it's crazy i never
i'm over it
really nobody
nobody's backing me up here he's got a
sock in his mouth this time it literally
a sock
whoa wait that's not him what the [ __ ]
okay i'm out on this one
you've been engaging with his videos and
you didn't come to the conclusion
yourself that
i could never tell what was going on
with him because he's i never seen a jaw
like that
i think you're blinded by the jawline
hey you look like a baba bowie character
i mean i don't see how that's not
interesting or funny
i'm fascinated that you're fascinated oh
stop
i found it really fascinating okay how
about this one then ela
how about this barber oh no are these
guys for real you tell me
wait is that how kim stone does it i was
about to say it's keemstar look at that
that looks
natural as [ __ ] man that's a game star
very important stuff
you think keemstar um
because i don't see [ __ ] that dark like
queer dark don't exist
do they oh no yeah that's what i'm
saying so yeah you might that's [ __ ]
up
but i just like how natural it looks
like i know i know people paint their
beards like i know dj khaled darkens the
edge of his beard
to make it look like perfect yeah but
it's more like makeup yeah
but this is the supernatural that's why
i like it
another one thank you
here he does a bunch of them they're all
supernatural looking
let me find another one another one
this guy is like a genius bro look at
this
oh my god he's the best at what he does
this guy's hair is not even black
it's yeah this guy
is one of the best in the game here's
another one again this is just [ __ ]
on my feed like i'm you can't tell me
dick doc isn't the best platform
that's a natural look it's the tape
doesn't even work that well you see
those little
you look okay watch when he takes that
one off
oh yeah very important stuff he'll clean
that up
yeah i love it i'll go oh [ __ ] here's a
kid getting it done not you don't even
have a page player yet
dude he taped his whole face down
let's go that's a natural look girls
that's [ __ ] up where are you at
what is the point
man this is crazy here's another one
oh no oh [ __ ] it got stuck in his nose
this one is 4.8 million so
it's crushing it
look at that line boy natural
[ __ ] ready to go to the club
yes shout out to his family yes sir
um if i can't get a jawline
like the baba booey guy i'm gonna get a
beard like
like these guys girl you look
and i got news for you that means you
get hey come on i'm just admiring a
man's beard how dare you
ice
oh here's one more one more for the road
this might be my taj plano favorite
honestly
i don't know this one's pretty amazing
we need audio for this one down
hi yes can i get a can i get some of the
fresh guacamole wow
what
did you wait to place your order what do
you do or do you just kind of be like
maybe not today guacamole
i love that it's guac being advertised
too
makes me want mexican food wow
that really makes you think of food i'm
hungry
i'll eat some wow
look look here's the deal
all right well
is that it what does joel have to say
about this
let's see let's end the day with joel
austin we haven't tried sermons so let's
see what's
i mean i feel like he's giving me
sermons every time i click a button i
don't really know what the difference is
let's see
bro start the sermon it's a joy to come
into your homes and
if you're ever in our area please stop
by and be a part of one of our services
i promise you we will make you feel
better dude give me the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
yeah bro let's do the sermon i got the
button to cut the [ __ ]
oh my god and that was like that was
audio pulled from
a sermon well i didn't even record it
exclusively for this cube
so all of these i can tell are all
pulled because there's like
faint clapping in the background so
there's no
original sound bites
i like to start with something funny and
one day up in heaven
god said to the men i want you to form
two lines
one line is for the men who were the
head of the house
the other line is for the men who let
the woman be the head of the house
god said man i'm ashamed of you i
created you to be the head
but only one man stood up to make me
proud
he looked at him and said tell them son
how did you manage to be the only one
in this line the man looked confused he
said i don't know
my wife told me to stand here
funnily enough it's not really a joke
about god it's just a joke about being
cucked by your wife
and it's also just chauvinistic yeah i
mean chauvinistic right thank you
thank you so much all right thank you so
much
it's like oh thank you ethan for letting
me work thank you
you're welcome you're such a nice
supporting thank you
work thank you thank you okay thank you
mistress
let's be honest i'm in that second line
hey
i'm just being i'm just being honest
it's not even like because my wife's the
head of the household it's like she just
told me to be here
how about a daily affirmation what's
favorites do i have
i guess i don't have any favorites my
wife went out for pizza without me
oh that's an interesting sermon
yeah that's that's the opposite of
affirmation supernatural favor over your
lie
oh i got a yo eli you ready to get
turned on right now
more like you're gonna get you ready to
get baba bowie something about to bust
bubba baba boom yes titties
big ass titties
that's what he looks like is that isn't
that hilarious to you
come on now this is why i feel when i
watch this tick tock come on now boy
thank you thank you peace and love i
declare
god's incredible blessings over your
life
you will see an explosion of god's
goodness
a sudden widespread increase you will
experience
the surpassing greatness of god's favor
it will elevate you to a level
higher than you ever dreamed it's this
is affirmation
the worst thing i've ever met
okay well we have a lot to look forward
to to see
uh um then we're stuck on a little
screen i think oh
you fixed it uh we have a lot to look
forward to to see how our
our gorilla the gorilla glue situation
is hopefully we'll get an answer from
her
and um other than that we got
daily reminders of um we want to give a
little
insight into what happened with the last
episode
no no movie magic then okay
i already asked ila she said movie magic
i said should we talk about it she said
better better to keep
you guys do know you can't really like
talk live about whether you want to talk
about something or not that's true
no we have already done it great
something is about to bust all right
well i guess that's it
so thanks dan
um anything else guys anyone want to add
anything else
you guys want to talk about dark souls
yeah
you beat too right easily easily
would you guys watch me stream dark
souls 3
i've always been horrible at dark souls
and i said you know what
i think it's because i didn't understand
like when you open the stat screen
you it looks like a [ __ ] roulette
table i'm like what am i looking at
so i've spent the time i got the ps5 i
played demon souls i played dark souls 1
i played dark souls 2.
i dominated them all do you understand
i'm
[ __ ] god of dark souls i
watched a little bit last night and it
just looks like one punch man
because i was playing new game plus and
either says it looks like one punch man
because i'm just
i kill everybody in one hand and they
all die ethan
massively over leveled he's like level
600 or something no i'm not i'm level
four i'm 405.
but there was this i like farming
because it's fun but
but there was this one looks ridiculous
yeah i'm using the smelter hammer which
is like this
comically oversized hammer that you need
70 strength to do
to yield and um i just i pancake
everybody
chad's being very supportive
where should i stream it that's what i
was wondering where's the proper channel
to do it which
channel do you guys see fit
i personally i wouldn't like it to be on
the main h3 channel because
just let it be i feel like that's just a
story fire abc
artifacts they're back let me story
fire's back can you stream on story fire
probably not i'm gonna need some kind of
deal i'm gonna need some kind of deal
with them
put me in touch with tyler the oakley
who's the owner
twitch i don't think it's tyler oakley
twitch they unpartnered me i told you
guys
they literally unpardon me when we
switch back to youtube they [ __ ]
they betrayed me and what's ironic is
that i would go back and stream there
right right but they [ __ ] lost me
from being so bitter that they literally
unpardon me
i told you guys the story about twitch
they unpartnered me
and then they still owed me money and so
when i said yo where's my
payment they said oh can you sign up for
the partner program again so
we can pay you and i was like [ __ ] you
pay me clowns
so you know ab says or i mean
love says sign up for the amazon prime
this is a good point because that amazon
prime money is like
free money right that being said
with peace and love they um pardon me
only fence i say in the chat you guys
wanna watch me play naked
dick cam it's just my dick all flaccid
oh that would be amazing
cut cut to my dick cam
i see a lot of people either saying the
highlights or the ethan and neela
channel
highlight what about yeah i mean the
ethernet illa channel is pretty good but
um love says you can you can get subs as
an affiliate
they're just they did they they beefed
me they demeaned me do you understand
they they burned the bridge with me
twitch for no reason just because they
were butthurt like hello
oh wow good that was incredibly fast
so but here's what's exciting about dark
souls 3 it's true that we did already
stream in the past on ethernet so it
wouldn't be
that weird to do it there
can we just rename it h3 gaming hub
h3 gaming uh old fat gamer i want to
make a new channel called old fat gamer
oh man
do you guys like if i started streaming
channel do you like old fat gamer
the old fat gamer it's not bad
well you're fat you're fat fat fat fat
you're a fat fat fatty you guys probably
have a good name for it i mean i guess
people always say i should use the h3
brand
i personally was like i'll just stream
on the main channel like [ __ ] it who
gives a [ __ ] about that dead ass channel
you know we'll do it live
but here's what's exciting i've never
played dark souls 3
right and i
am a pro now i think they like the fat
uh old gamer
fupa gaming really you guys like fat old
gamer because it's kind of like the
antithesis of everything
it initially goes to fog fat oh
fog gamer that'll get the fog gamer
you know i'm foggy i'm old i'm depressed
i'm [ __ ] uh
decrepit the senile
fog gamer well there's already gamer in
fog
yeah that old gamer gamer
yo you all really like the new channel
idea fat old gamer
because i do kind of want to start
playing start fresh gerd gaming
you're gaming good gaming gg that is
amazing that's not bad
gerd
the thing is though i do i really need a
new channel i have like five channels
this would be like
well but we don't use that or two
they're just there as like
a part of history right
so if i make it you know what i i just i
don't like um
like we changed we grew up we look older
i don't like it all being together right
and maybe it's just a weird
thing in my head it's a new meme it's a
new you just
feel like that shouldn't be mixed in
with whatever is happening today
i wonder if it's better though to do
like to get someone to edit it if i do
like fat old gamer and then someone
edits the parts
it's probably not as fun as a live
stream
i don't know that's uh fat ass gamer
what's that acronym mean
stand for easy
hold on hila what's fat ass gamer hold
on
stop and i got news for you
wait maybe i'm the fat ass gamer i think
we should do it
stop it what i'm a badass and a gamer
stop
can we make a vote between fog and gerd
because you seem to like gerd i think
fog is way stronger
fat old gamer or because like if you
don't know
gerd doesn't mean anything like f fat
old gamer is kind of funny at least
you don't need to know anything to
understand i'm trying to get all those
uh
i'm trying to get all those young clicks
because you know if you want to have a
popular gaming channel it's all kids so
fat old gamer is gonna reel them in i
need that clout
do you really want more work though
because it's just gonna be more work for
you yeah i mean it's supposed to just be
fun because i'm already playing and i
say oh it'd be fun to play with so
people can watch because i'm so good
i'm [ __ ] insanely good at this game
by the way i'm speed running the demon
souls 2 now and like new game plus and
i'm like
i completed the first quarter of the
game yeah dark souls 2.
complete the first quarter of the game
in literally like an hour
yeah yeah yeah you're level 600.
i'm 450. dan chill daddy i think we
should do a poll but i see a lot of gurd
in the chat and
let's do a call yeah ian cena pull here
dan you want to spam that
uh sure so where the vote is fat old
gamer
or gerd gaming but you know everyone's
gonna call me
everyone's gonna be like more like [ __ ]
gamer i feel like people will use that a
lot
well you can just ban that word
it's auto banned yeah oh i mean i
wouldn't call myself
fog i always call myself foul camera i'm
not i don't wanna
i don't wanna vote gerd gaming pretty
strong
showing what is love saying
what is love love you can pin things as
the owner
in chat oh you can pin stuff dan
apparently oh so you don't need to spam
yeah
there you go that's way better spam is
fun though all right
this is way better though let's be
honest all right well gert is winning
gerd gaming
i mean the gerd is good it explains why
i'm coughing and hacking like a maniac
but do most people even know what gerd
is
sure not our fan base although corpse
husband is gerd so
die so if he's popular then maybe i then
i've got i have that in common with him
and he's super popular
of all time i we need to get young
clicks you guys we need young
clicks gerd gabe
oh my god
all right i got to think about this dan
you're going to help me do a setup what
kind of rig should we do
well do you want to keep playing on your
ps5 or do you want to just do it on pc
um i guess i don't care i'll use a
controller either way
that's true i like playing on a tv i
mean it's bigger i mean you can still do
that with a pc too
pc is probably it'll be easier okay well
there's interest in one place
there's interest you know
and great gaming it's closer than i
expected though
60 40. there's a lot of there's a lot of
fog out there
all right that's the show the thing is
i'm gonna i can't
i'm gonna play start playing it today so
it's like either you're with me or
you're not with me so how do we do this
you know what you mean
you want to start today how am i how not
i guess i could
keep going the new game plus
true all right we'll talk about it
honestly
you've been going through the series in
order the next game up is actually
bloodborne
not dark souls 3 but it's not in the
same universe well neither is demon
souls
yes it is no it's not uh yes
it is separate from an argument
dude they're always talking about demon
souls in the lore with the first four
i'm telling the first four souls out of
the flame
stop dude it's part of the same lore i
you are
not correct oh my god does anyone care
about this competition
okay guys another straw poll is demon
souls part of the same lore as dark it
is enough for debate it's
it's a separate ip dude it's part of the
same lord it's the same universe
no it is not it is the same universe
it's the first four flames dude
and then the the whole the d the flame
that went to the pygmy is the dark soul
that's the dark soul uh-huh yeah that
sets the stage for the other games
yeah that's that's uh what you're
describing all happens in the first dark
souls
there's nothing to do with demons oh
really oh [ __ ] i get i'm getting him
mixed up
that is right everyone's agreeing with
dan mm-hmm oh [ __ ]
okay i'm wrong
i played it let me get my thoughts
together here but the point being
bloodborne
was the next one that was released and
um and
you know i sent you some info oh oh
ian's here with the receipts let's read
it
dark souls is the second game in the
soul series considered a spiritual
successor to demon souls
right so spirit yeah i mean obviously
they're very similar
second game in the soul
series right and bloodborne would be
considered part of that series as well
it usually is included from the software
from
software wanted to craft games similar
to demon souls but the exclusivity of
the ip to sony prevented them
from using the same name right sounds
like
look down look down at the bottom of the
screen oh yeah and they share
at least a common character patches
patches in both
of them oh damn yeah they're in all of
frontsoft's games
he's saying he's in bloodborne too it is
stated in the beginning of dark souls
that in the age of ancients the world
was filled with arch trees
and everlasting dragons it was shrouded
by fog
demon souls contains arch trees and
dragons
yeah i mean listen you're not gonna get
me to disagree that there's not
tons of similarities but it's a separate
ip so wait was the
dark souls one the one with the four
great flames yes oh
yeah everything you were describing was
the beginning so what the [ __ ] was demon
souls i don't even remember that game i
played it so long ago at this point
it was like a month ago yeah just been
i've just been on such a
binge i don't know yeah all blurs
together
well this is the end of the show people
are saying over it's like this is it
you don't have to stick around it
doesn't get better if you're over it you
can go
um b uh uh and
love we're asking uh to shout out the
new podcast tick tock that we have
oh podcast tick tock
h3 underscore podcast on tick tock i
mean it's spreading
it's doing its own working work
yeah it's doing its own work
please start streaming today that's what
i feel like too so how do i set that up
well after the show if you want me to
okay we'll talk about we'll talk shop me
and dad are going to talk about that
and see if um if we can get some old
[ __ ]
how about like how about this about this
old fat gamer doesn't go far enough
what i'm just here fat
hold on i'm trying to think of something
even more obscene
[ __ ] my diaper gaming
i got your word straight jack
okay well we're gonna we're gonna figure
it out i'm gonna see what i can do okay
all right
guys have a great weekend mwah we love
you we appreciate you
hey come on this stage three podcasts
after dark we got to get an iov
10.0 in slow motion
so anyway i probably will see you guys
streaming later tonight i don't know
wasn't there a new song to debut
yeah it's copyrighted so i'm going to do
it when it's not live so we can
have more flexibility but yeah zach made
a new
ping parody
i thought we had an easier time getting
away with it when it was live i thought
it was the
well copyright they don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean they'll get ya
right we did his other songs on the live
though that's what i'm saying
anyways doesn't matter all right guys
we're done
you're watching h23
you